[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à 7 ans j'ai compris que j'étais
différente
septembre 78 classes de CP dans les
Vosges il fait humide notre instituteur
nous emmène voir une exposition de
champignons
trop fière de moi je donne le nom en
latin de tous les champignons présents
mes parents sont convoqués pour
suspicion de bourrage de crâne ils sont
tous les deux profs nous passons tous
les trois sous surveillance
en fait j'avais mémorisé seul la semaine
précédente les étiquettes
grâce à mon papa qui organisait une
exposition de champignons dans son lycée
il était prof de surce naturelle et ma
petite tâche était de déposer les
étiquettes j'avais mémorisé les mots en
latin
bref à 7 ans déjà on me demandait de ne
pas faire de vagues mes études m'ont
causé peu de défis intellectuels j'ai
accumulé quantité de diplôme dans des
grandes écoles en France à l'étranger et
d'ailleurs même dans ma vie d'adulte je
continue toujours à me former et aller à
l'école
apprendre c'est mon truc
mais des filles sont ailleurs mon
problème c'est la tempête de mon cerveau
j'ai une forme d'hyper stimulation
intellectuelle qui me pousse toujours à
essayer d'apprendre des trucs nouveaux
c'est éreintant ça m'empêche parfois de
dormir et si je tombe sur un sujet qui
me passionne ça peut aller jusqu'à
l'épuisement
pendant longtemps à l'école comme en
entreprise on m'a demandé de rester dans
la norme d'être un bon petit soldat de
rester dans mes prévoirs prérogatives
mais j'ai toujours été un petit peu
cette mauvaise herbe des champs vosgiens
qui dépassent un peu
cette mèche rebelle qui existe un petit
peu toute seule j'ai rarement réussi à
être dans le sens du poil et j'ai
toujours un espèce de chemin décalé bref
je me sens toujours un peu agitatrice
comme un esprit disruptif un puzzèbre
sur les bords et aujourd'hui quel
bonheur parce que l'époque est enfin
propice aux esprits disruptifs ce sont
ces rebelles constructifs qui favorisent
l'intelligence collective qui font
héberger des idées un peu novatrices et
qui font bouger les lignes alors je vais
essayer de vous expliquer peut-être en
deux temps d'abord comment j'ai compris
qu'elles étaient mes talents comme des
gilles et puis surtout comment je suis
parvenue à en exploiter certains
comprendre d'abord alors pensez trop et
réfléchir tout le temps
pourquoi ça vient mais en fait c'est une
histoire de cerveau droit et de cerveau
gauche
biologiquement notre cerveau est composé
de deux hémisphères séparés communiquant
entre eux par le corps calleux le
cerveau gauche et verbal méthodique
analytique il a une pensée rationnelle
circonscrite et l'analyse les faits avec
logique et rigueur
le cerveau droit privilégie
l'information sensorielle l'instinct
l'intuition sa pensée est globale
systémique
arborescente foisonnante
en fonction de l'hémisphère qui domine
non seulement nos cerveaux de
s'intéressent pas à tous les mêmes
toutes les mêmes informations tous les
mêmes signaux mais l'information digérée
est également traitée de manière
différente ce sont bien finalement deux
mondes différents qui cohabitent et les
mondes sont parfois tellement différents
qu'on a l'impression de venir de Planète
différentes
alors question je sais pas si ça marche
comme pour Gilles mais question pour
vous merci
[Musique]
je voudrais savoir dans cette salle qui
est de droite et qui est de gauche
attention je parle bien évidemment de
votre cerveau
levez la main s'il vous plaît ce qui
pense avoir un cerveau après dominance
gauche
OK et je vais la main ce qui pense avoir
un cerveau après dominance droite
et bien sachez que dans la population
générale autour de 75 80% plutôt des
hémisphères à gauche et 15 20% des
hémisphères à droite
les personnes disruptives en cette
capacité à pouvoir mobiliser plus
facilement les compétences des deux
hémisphères et à combiner les deux
approches
je suis cerveau droit je travaille chez
Lizzie dans une entreprise industrielle
de la région Belfort qui fabrique des
solutions d'assemblage pour les secteurs
aéronautiques automatiques et médical
je suis un cerveau droit féminin dans un
océan de cerveau gauche masculin un
monde d'ingénieur
formé à respecter tous les process
mon travail chez Lizzie consiste
effectivement à aider la société à se
transformer sur trois thématiques la
première la transformation digitale la
seconde la trajectoire la transformation
vers la décarbonation de l'industrie et
la dernière tout ce qui va toucher à
l'attractivité diversité et inclusion
elle a ensuite comment on exploite ses
talents effectivement pour permettre un
potentiel de s'exprimer il faut des
ingrédients de base bien sûr mais il
faut aussi tout un tas de facteurs de
chance et de leçon de vie qui vous
mettent le pied à l'étrier qui vous
permettra
je vais vous raconter toutes ces leçons
de vie qui ont été les murs porteurs de
mon existence
1980 j'ai 9 ans maman quitte papa elle
part avec ses deux enfants sous le bras
vers une destination suffisamment
lointaine papa a vidé les comptes
bancaires pensant lui couper les ailes
on débarque dans un HLM sans mobilier
maman a un nouveau travail
noël arrive une image très forte dans
mon existence un gymnase blafard avec
une lumière très blanche et une
banderole affreuse Noël des enfants sans
joie
à ma hauteur d'enfant
je comprends qu'on est pauvre
mais maman travaille beaucoup et en deux
ans elle va nous sortir de cette
pauvreté
comme beaucoup probablement qu'elle a eu
peur mais n'a pas perdu de temps à se
plaindre et là agit en deux ans
et grâce au comportement de maman sans
comprendre j'ai fait émerger des murs
porteurs de ma vie à 9 ans sans en
mesurer l'impact je me suis fait trois
promesses dans cette espèce d'horrible
gymnase blafard
première promesse je ne veux pas être
pauvre
deuxième promesse je vais être
exploratrice j'ai besoin de quitter mon
village pour tenter ma chance
troisième promesse je ne veux dépendre
de personne
c'est promesses je ne les ai pas toutes
tenues
promesse numéro 1 ne pas être pauvre mes
études terminées je veux tout je suis
increvable je deviens la plus jeune
cadre de Vivendi je me fais débaucher
par peichiné je prends l'ascenseur des
grandes entreprises industrielles
françaises je suis sur diplômée bilingue
et je suis la piste de l'argent
mon premier salaire dépassera largement
celui de mes parents
deuxième promesse exploratrice
facteur de chance j'ai eu cette chance
incroyable d'appartenir à la génération
Erasmus
j'ai fait mes études et mes stages à
l'étranger je pars au Yuki en Inde aux
États-Unis en Allemagne partout
j'apprends partout je m'adapte je me
sens citoyenne du monde je pars même au
Canada faire un MBA j'ai rencontré mon
mari il s'appelle Luc en trois semaines
nous prenons la décision de nous marier
décision de cerveau droit fulgurante
instinctive et totalement sereine
dernière promesse ne dépendre jamais de
personne
aïe
cette promesse je ne l'ai pas tenu la
vie m'a appris qu'on dépend toujours de
l'amour de nos proches des gens qui nous
sont chers je suis dépendante pour le
meilleur et pour le pire
le meilleur c'est la vie merveilleuse de
famille que nous avons construit avec
Luc le pire
c'est quand on me l'a enlevé
à 45 ans Luc décède un cancer foudroyant
je deviens veuve j'ai 4 enfants mon
petit dernier à 5 ans
pour la première fois depuis ma
naissance mon cerveau s'arrête
tracer plat
comme la fréquence respiratoire de Luc
plus de pensées parasites
plus de capacité de décision plus
d'intuition juste des émotions brutes et
de la douleur c'est comme la télé en
noir et blanc vous avez des images vous
n'entendez plus les paroles
je suis devenue sourde et muette ça
durera un an
durant cette période douloureuse je
traverse les jours en mode zombie
hyperactif pour ne pas sombrer je ne
sais plus dormir sauf d'épuisement et
pourtant tous les soirs vers 3-4 heures
du matin
j'ouvre les yeux en une fraction de
seconde et me sens totalement éveillé
paradoxalement en journée mon cerveau
est hors service et la nuit il
surchauffe il travaille à essayer de
résoudre le dilemme de la mort de Luc
et comme le processeur interne d'un
ordinateur qui ne parvient pas à
exécuter une tâche il surchauffe une à
d'autres solutions que le reboot pour
éviter l'implosion
pendant un an mon cerveau s'est rebouté
toutes les nuits il n'a pas résolu le
sens de toutes ces souffrances j'éprouve
encore de la colère intermittente
pour autant derrière ce brouillard
émerge un certain nombre de leçons de
vie la première bien évidente oui
j'étais dépendante de Luc
il était le sel de mon existence
il était le phare qui bord de ma route
la joie qui illumine la confiance qui
porte il était ma dopamine
et aujourd'hui c'est toute seule que je
dois réinventer mon chemin et c'est tout
seul que je dois trouver ma dopamine
pour avancer
deuxième petite leçon qui émerge ce
brouillard celle-là je vous promets vous
la connaissez toutes pourtant très peu
la pratique il faut vivre au présent
je veux être aujourd'hui celle que j'ai
envie d'être je n'ai pas envie qu'on a
m'autorise à être celle que je veux être
de ce jour-là j'ai été autrement libre
j'ose aujourd'hui parce que demain sera
trop tard je me suis libérée du jugement
des autres je ne demande plus la
permission j'explique
la vie est vraiment injuste et
arbitraire elle vous laisse généralement
deux options se plaindre ou agir
aujourd'hui bizarrement je me sens
globalement plus forte plus forte parce
que j'ai appris à vivre au présent et je
prends tous les cadeaux que la vie met
sur ma route comme celui la très
inattendue de faire cette intervention
là devant vous partagez avec vous ce
moment je suis globalement plus forte
parce que j'ai appris à dire non je ne
m'inflige plus des sujets qui ne sont
pas les miens
je suis aussi beaucoup plus fragile
qu'avant parce que je dépends plus que
jamais de l'amour de mes enfants et de
mes proches
je suis beaucoup plus fragile qu'avant
parce que j'ai définitivement perdu
l'insouciance et la légèreté de la vie
je suis forte fragile et imparfaite
comme finalement tout le monde
quelques dernières paroles si vous ne
saisissez pas ce que vous voulez
soyez certains vous ne l'ont jamais
alors définissez le succès avec vos
propres termes
travailler le avec vos propres règles et
construisez vous une vie que vous êtes
fière de vivre
je vous promets le plus dur c'est de se
décider à agir le reste ça n'est que de
la tenacité
vous devez au monde de faire ce pourquoi
vous êtes naturellement doué
et enfin un dernier petit mot pour les
personnes destructives autour de vous
identifier les regardez les leçons rares
elles sont précieuses elles portent
probablement en elle la résolution des
problématiques futures déjà engendrées
par notre présent à condition toutefois
qu'on les y autorise
impose ta chance serre ton bonheur et va
vers ton risque à te regarder il
s'habitueront
merci
[Applaudissements]